have his opponent from this round
danielle naradiski in studio with us
dania you clearly did not have the kind
of tournament you would have liked to
have and you got this position against
uh
against sam and we're debating the pros
and cons and and the fighting spirit and
all that what are your thoughts about
playing him today yeah i mean first of
all i want to apologize to all the fans
and and to you guys
i hate it when people do that not
sarcastically it's uh
it's not what i want to do but i you
know yesterday's game particularly was
very back breaking i should have drawn
it
i've been getting more exhausted
throughout the tournament i know it's a
crappy excuse but um i figured you know
i'd play e4 if sam wanted to play he
sometimes plays the french so i thought
okay if he plays the french i'm not
going to take on d5 we're going to play
a game
if he plays knight f6 instead of bishop
c5 it's going to be a game but if he
plays bishop c5 i figured
i'd make a draw i really didn't want to
you know lose the last game in the
tournament i think overall it was a you
know there were ups and downs in this
event i have some games i'm really proud
of but again i
uh
obviously this is not something i want
to do but um
you know it's i was tired and i again i
i really didn't want to end the
tournament on two losses so
i decided to go for it overall it's been
a return to the championship for you
how do you assess the ups and the downs
and the what are the lessons that you've
learned yeah i mean i think overall i'm
quite happy with my performance i mean i
i think i didn't neither lost nor gained
any ratings so my performance was was my
rating obviously minus two optically is
not the score i wanted to have i wanted
to get 50
however
i think the positives are obviously my
two wins i'm really proud of um
and i had a couple of draws that i was
really happy about i was able to hold
linear and wesley and i didn't lose any
games in five moves as i thought i would
um
there was a lot of stuff i was unhappy
about i felt like i was rusty i i was
getting tired toward the end of each
game and the mistake started to pile on
this happened against sam shankland not
seven this i made no mistakes in this
game it's a perfect game did this happen
against uh shanklin against wesley i was
completely lost at one point so i really
need to work on my stamina
and i think i need to work on my end
game technique particularly in equal
positions i mean these 2700s they know
how to press and how to squeeze you know
water from
from nothing and they create chances out
of thin air so
uh with that being said it was a great
honor to play um
i would you know this is like a dream
for me so so much to learn from and i
think i can i can come back stronger if
i have the have the honor of being
invited to subsequent u.s championships
well certainly deserving of this honor
let me ask you you're a streamer these
days
how much are you going to combine
streaming with the hard work you need to
improve as a chess player that's a great
question i'm asking myself this question
um and it's not just streaming you know
i do commentating and teaching and
you know i only had two months to
prepare for this tournament with all of
that stuff on top of everything so you
know my expectations weren't too high
yeah i mean i i love what i do i love
commentating i love streaming
uh at the same time i think this
tournament has really
set me on fire in terms of my desire to
to get my rating up and at least hit
26.50 in the near future so
i'm going to be shifting the balance a
little bit and trying to make time for
chess training and playing the us
masters
in charlotte over thanksgiving break so
i'm definitely going to be playing some
tournaments next year
and it's it's a brutal chess landscape
out there these days everybody's
incredibly good
so
you know i'm just gonna i'm gonna do
what i can but yeah it's a tough balance
for sure all right it's good to hear
that you're gonna be playing more chess
we want to see some of your brilliant
games you've been on my stream before
showing some of those amazing games
you've been into a lot of fun
congratulations on a solid performance
like you said not tanking despite not
having been in great form and good luck
with the rest of your chest career
thanks maurice appreciate it celebrate
those wins dania
yeah time to hit the bar again
good luck to you